okay we're getting ready for
our next day we are here in well we're
not here yet we're we're arriving in
busan in about an hour
we're late
all of the tours were canceled for the
day because we are on the outer edge of
a super typhoon
that's hit in japan and uh
last night was ridiculous
so bad it was like being on a roller
coaster i think i may have flew up
out of bed and back down now
it was bad it was bad it was bad but
love and also like did you feel it like
it hit the ship hit something we maybe
hit a whale or something i don't know
it's really hard
anyway it was it was rough sleeping i
got bags under my eyes
nina's doing her makeup
yeah anyway fun fun times we're so we're
arriving in busan a little late and we
have a short day there anyway because we
have to get to uh beijing so we're gonna
do some breakfast and then uh hopefully
we'll land soon and we can explore busan
so we're still on the boat it is uh 9
30. we're supposed to arrive at six in
the morning it's 9 30 we're still not
even close uh the super typhoon kind of
pushed us
uh off course and we're very slow to get
there and nothing is open right now so
everybody's just kind of congregating on
the decks there's no entertainment
there's no music there's no games
everybody's just getting frustrated and
uh waiting to get off so instead of
joining in the frustration we came back
to the cabin i uh picked up some food
got a chocolate glazed donut and a
granola parfait and we're gonna watch
some movies oh announcement what's the
captain ladies and gentlemen i'm afraid
i was a bit optimistic earlier on um
saying that
we could get into busan today i'm afraid
that's not the case we went up to the
harbour entrance there and the wind was
blowing
50 to 60 knots increased to that that's
storm force winds
and i'm afraid that's way beyond our
capabilities to enter port i'm afraid
we'll have to
then proceed back to sea again okay so
no korea all right i think i'm going to
put on one of those patches right
because we tomorrow's the day at sea so
we have two days at sea now basically no
but where are they heading though we're
heading to beijing
i'm sure everybody's freaking out
downstairs especially for those koreans
oh the koreans can't even oh man there's
this whole group of koreans who came and
they're getting ready to get off the
boat this is their stop to leave and go
home and they're gonna have to go to
beijing and then find their way home
wow
that sucks the koreans who were dancing
and they were singing gangnam style that
sucks they had all their luggage and
everything downstairs
man
okay well we're in a better situation
than uh
than
them
so this is a view outside there's a
strong
wind going northeast it's creating huge
waves and strong winds outside that
luckily we're going with the wind now
but you can see that there's huge
waves kind of forming it's to the point
where they've taped off
all the exits and we're not allowed to
go outside
nina might break that rule though she's
kind of a real breaker
but uh anyway
rough waters
let's go have some lunch
bruce cut them with um
avocado and tomato and cheese provolone
cheese oh nina's adding some some
balsamic vinegar and oil to it i think
that's a good call
next up is um clam chowder with tomatoes
i think they said nina has another soup
chicken
spinach and
rice chicken spinach and rice
you have a good feeling
okay next up what are you what are you
having this is the indian stir fry
noodles something with spicy chili sauce
fuji in a cream sauce with shrimp and
parsley i think i'm always a sucker for
cream sauce pastas so
with some extra parmesan on top
i'm not feeling so well so i think after
this i'm going to go lie down and nina's
going to go look for more food
because she's always curious what food
is available
so we ate uh lunch at 11 30.
uh then came back to the room
and watched the movie and slept and we
just got up and what time is it babe
6 30.
the good news is i'm feeling better
i got uh i'm eating an apple
and i'm having some crackers
and i remember on a previous cruise when
i was
feeling seasick they they gave out
apples and crackers to people so there's
something about that that uh
makes you feel better but uh hopefully
that combined with the patch come out
with the sleep
um makes me ready to go i'm feeling
better so i think we're gonna go do
something um we'll explore and
see what happens we're gonna put the
please refresh my room
and even though it's
6 30 at night we haven't had a room
cleaned yet
we came to do dancing
and they changed the schedule on us and
they're showing
a rugby game behind so
maybe they changed the schedule because
they had to
stay at sea today
why don't we go ask
downstairs see if they change the
schedule
so they apparently cancelled the uh
the ballroom dancing because it was a
huge demand for rugby
and uh they're not planning to put it
back on tonight so no dancing tonight
but we're gonna come for dinner figure
out what's on the menu and then and then
we'll see we're gonna do the rest of the
night
how do you like your dessert oh yeah
yeah that's good that is some good stuff
so we went to the top deck to get some
more food even though we're super full
but i just loaded up on crackers and
apples just in case i get seasick again
we've got uh some ammunition
and nina is taking the daily sudoku
sharpening the pencil we're going to the
comedy show
any irish people here
the alcoholics are back all right
it's our last uh sea day here on the
boat
we're gonna go for breakfast soon we had
a good sleep lunch
we had a good sleep nina how much did
you sleep i don't know over 10 hours no
i think like 12 hours really okay let's
go nina slept a lot
i like your shirt babe
yeah thanks hmm yummy okay
we have balloons
congratulations all right we're gonna go
eat some
some breakfast and then see what's on
our agenda for the day to have some fun
on our last day at sea we're getting off
the boat we have dry light coming up dry
land coming up giant land coming up
nina's all excited nina's all excited
look at the cute eyes
stop it
it's so much calmer today
this is why we're not feeling sick
awesome
i like the calm weather
we're gonna follow nina where we're
going babe
lunch breakfast breakfast lunch hard to
get good seats here uh close to the
buffet so i saw one as he walked in and
figured i gotta go get this what are you
having babe
oh chicken kanji is back how was your
face when you saw the kitchen kanji
you're excited
round two what did you get babe same
thing
more more chicken conch and you got some
fruit
what are you gonna do baby
we're in the laundry room
nina's doing our laundry for the week
and we just came back from a photo place
we had a formal portrait done and they
framed it for us so here's what it looks
like
it's nice i like it nice time yeah so
we're going to learn about uh
tianjin in beijing and what to do i'm
still feeling bad ready yeah
you're okay
we're excited to get off the boat though
i know oh my god you excited
yeah that extra day at sea is kind of
killer yeah so tomorrow we wake up and
we go to beijing
no more boat
no more wobbly no more super typhoon
cool all right well we're gonna enjoy
this seminar and
see what happens
so we're really excited because i
finally had sushi
so we got sushi for lunch and a whole
bunch of stuff we got shrimp
cocktail which i was uh
excited to have for a while we got some
curry with rice
we got some watermelon some breaded
scallops some
what did nina get here we got some
salmon and pulled pork and beef and a
whole bunch of stuff that we're
excited to try so it's time for lunch
the biggest biggest lunch we've ever had
on the boat yeah
so i spent most of the afternoon in bed
napping relaxing
feeling seasick nina's feeling a little
dizzy too but we're gonna go out because
we can't be in the cabin all day uh
get some alcohol and then go maybe go
dancing eat dinner although we're not
hungry we'll see where the day takes us
so
this here represents the importance of
sampling your products because you get
me a guy who doesn't drink a lot of
alcohol and who is not a huge vodka fan
and we went to that one taste test day
and tried it and we're both impressed
with it that now we're here
buying it so the one we're getting is
this one elite by stoli
it's totally
china
anyway so stamp your products people
makes people want to buy so we're going
to pick one of these up sample your
products people we're here for some
ballroom dancing
and there's nobody here
so we have the floor to ourselves
and practice little waltz
if you want the real goods i share my
best advice for entrepreneurs every week
in my newsletter click the link below to
check it out it's free
hi i'm jason j ross fonseca of
risonline.com and i want to say evan
carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun
inspiring and it's the only newsletter i
prioritize and look forward to period